لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنى من عماننا لواء
فايز الدويريه الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه السيد اللواء نادي ليست اول
مره او اول عمليه تتهم بها اسرائيل في
سوريا ما الجديد برايك على صعيد هذه
العمليه الاخيره
والاهداف ثانيه
يعني اولا العمليات الاسرائيليه
هي في عمليات متصاعده وبدات تحديدا منذ
عمليه اطلق عليها خارج الصندوق عندما تم
تدمير المفاعل النووي في منطقه دير الزور
وفي عام 2007 من 2013 بدات تصعيد بعد ان
تدخلت ايران وحزب الله وبدات تمركز
الايراني وبدا التصعيد كان تقريبا في اخر
خمس سنوات اكثر من الف ضربه وجهت داخل
سوريا اي بمعدل تقريبا اكثر من 200 هدف او
طلعه جويه او قصف بصاروخ خلال كل عام الان
ما هو الشيء الجديد فيها الشيء الجديد ان
معظم الطلعات الجويه والغارات الاسرائيليه
تستهدف نقاط عسكريه ذات علاقه اما بشحنات
اسلحه او بمعسكرات او
معامل لتطوير الاسلحه خاصه في منطقه
صفيتها ووادي جهنم لكن عمليات انتقائيه
داخل تجمعات سكنيه هذه عمليات محدوده جدا
استخدمت اكثر من مره باكثر من طريقه عندما
يكون هناك هدفا
دسما المعارضه السوريه اشارت في بعض
مواقعها هذا اليوم انه تم قتل عميد في
الجيش السوري وقتل شخصيه ايرانيه هامه
ولكن
اي من الايرانيين قد اصيب جراء هذه
العمليه طيب سيدي اللواء اذا وضعنا هذا
الهجوم في اطار التوتر المتزايد
والاستهداف المتبادل بين الجانبين ترى كيف
ستنعكس هذه العمليه
مستقبلا يعني هل يمكن ان تتصاعد الامور
وتصل الى حد ان يكون هناك رد ايراني في
مكان اخر ربما
يعني الردود الايرانيه اصبحت شبه مالوفه
انا عقد تهاجم احد ناقلات النفط في بحر
عمان او على مقربه من مضيق هرمز او في
البحر الاحمر في احد المرات اما ان يكون
هناك رد داخل العمق
فلسطين
المحتله لا اعتقد ذلك لانه لم ايران لا
تعترف لكن اذا عدنا الى الوراء
اشهر عديده نجد ان ايران قامت بنقل جثامين
الكثير من القتلى سواء قتلوا في الصراع
السوري الداخلي او جراء القصف الاسرائيلي
لكن كذلك اذا عدنا وبحثنا عن اسماء القاده
الايرانيين الذي قتلوا في غارات اسرائيليه
سنجد العديد من هؤلاء القاده الذين قتلوا
سواء في الكسوه او في صفاتها او في تيفور
او حتى في مطار دمشق في المبنى الزجاجي
اذا دعني
ايران لا تعترف بان لها قوات او ان فقط هي
ارسلت مستشارين كما ان ايران تنكر اسرائيل
لا تعترف بانها رسميا بانها نفذت اذا دعني
اقول كانه قتال منخفض التصعيد وفي الظلام
لا يعترف اي جانب بان له قوات والجانب
الاخر لا يعترف رسميا انه اسرائيل وستبقى
الدائره اعترفت اسرائيل بانها ستستهدف
المصالح الايرانيه
وبالتالي هذه التهديدات ان كانت متبادله
وغير ذلك هل يمكن ان تبقى في نطاق ضيق ام
تراها ستتسع ربما في نطاق اكثر خطوره
يعني لا اعتقد ان تتوسع ضمن الاطار
الجغرافي لسوريا لماذا اسرائيل تنفذ
الضربات ليس من داخل الاجواء السوريه في
معظم الحالات لانه اذا دخلت للعمق الى شرق
الفرات او الى مطار التيفور او الى السخنه
تدخل الطائرات الاسرائيليه الاهداف حتى
الخط الخط الشرقيات الذي يمر في دمشق
تنفذها من الجولان المحتل ومن داخل فلسطين
وبالتالي اعتقد ان هذا الصراع سيبقى بهذا
المستوى لان ايران لا ترد اصلا حتى في مره
واحده سقطت الطائره
اسرائيليه بصاروخ قيل انه صاروخ سوري اس
300 وردت اسرائيل في اليوم التالي بقصف
موسع ايران لا تعتذر لا تعترف انها واجهت
خسائر لم تفقد احد اذا كانها تقول لن اق
الرد فيما اسرائيل وضعت اربعه خطوط حمراء
لم تسمح بتجاوزها اذا اتيحت لها الفرصه
وجميعها تتعلق بالاسلحه او نقل الاسلحه او
تصنيع الاسلحه او تواجد اهداف دسمه
كشخصيات عائده للحرس الثوري وتحديدا فيلق
القدس اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكريه والاستراتيجي متحدثا من عمان سيد
لواء شكرا لك على الافاده